space telescope is in a way
a little like galileo's first telescope
wherever galileo pointed his telescope
he made major new discoveries look at
the moon find mountains and craters look
at saturn you find rings look at the
milky way you find it is littered and
composed
of stars
if you could look back in time when
would you look back to
[Music]
early man
the time of the dinosaurs
or the birth of our planet
[Music]
[Music]
we like to say telescopes are like time
machines and of course the reason that
this is possible is because light takes
time to travel so the street lamp across
the street takes a teeny tiny fraction
of a second for the light to reach your
eye the light from the sun takes about
eight minutes to reach the earth so in
essence we're seeing the sun as it was
eight minutes ago
now a new telescope that's more powerful
than anything that's ever been sent into
space is looking at some of the farthest
and oldest objects yet
it's called the james webb space
telescope or jwst and it can see back to
the beginning of the universe
when the first galaxy started to form
and emit light after the big bang
one of the great things about telescopes
like this is they're really designed to
see the entire universe so
all the way to 13 and a half billion
years into the past all the way to our
cosmic backyard of the solar system and
everything in space and time in between
finally after 30 years in the making a
successful launch into space
50 successful deployments
miles traveled from earth
months of cooling to near absolute zero
and calibration
it has delivered its first full color
science quality images
[Music]
these images showcase the telescope's
powerful instruments and offer a preview
of the science projects to come
these first images really do signify the
start of science operations we have over
a year of observations already planned
some really exciting things that we
already have designed to do in the first
year of operations
the hope of scientists is to uncover the
greatest mysteries of the universe today
we would like to observe galaxies as far
away as possible red giant stars in the
disk of andromeda star forming regions
one is in the milky way our galaxy and
two nearby galaxies the magellanic
clouds the trappist-1 system what we can
call the rock star of exoplanet tnos
these are objects that are orbiting
beyond the orbit of neptune so in the
coldest regions of our solar system how
stars galaxies planets etc formed and
that really helps us understand how we
fit in
[Music]
so we have all these very specific you
know questions that we've planned to try
to answer
and i think we'll for sure answer those
but i think we'll also learn things that
we haven't even dreamed of yet
[Music]
liftoff of the space shuttle discovery
with the hubble space telescope our
window on the universe in 1990 the
hubble space telescope successfully
launched aboard the space shuttle
discovery
it's been serviced by humans in space
five times allowing it to be one of the
longest running and most expensive
science missions to date
for more than 30 years through its
powerful imaging system
it's changed our understanding of the
universe
galaxies
nebulae
and star clusters
have been seen like never before
the hubble space telescope grew from the
idea that by putting an observatory into
space above the atmosphere you could get
much sharper pictures without that
blurring that the earth's atmosphere
brings
so looking at places in our own milky
way where stars are being born and we're
beginning to see evidence for planets
being born in disks of gas and dust
swirling around those stars
things that weren't even thought of at
the time when hubble was built include
measuring the atmospheres of planets
going around other stars and then beyond
that of course the very big picture has
been looking at galaxies all the way
back close to the beginning of the
universe
perhaps one of the most well-known
images came from what's known as the
hubble deep field
instead of looking at previously known
galaxies observed from ground-based
telescopes they pointed hubble at a
relatively empty part of the sky and
took hundreds of long exposures over a
10-day period then combined them
this first image changed the way
humanity saw the universe
almost all of the roughly 3 000 objects
captured here is a previously unknown
galaxy
so hubble has actually helped us
illustrate the evolution of the universe
from the first cold gas and dust which
was lying around millions of years after
the big bang and how that coalesced and
agglomerated and swirled together to
form galaxies full of shining stars
so that's one of the great successes of
hubble so to follow on from that science
and see the birth of the first galaxies
we need a bigger telescope and we need
one that operates in the infrared and
that's the james webb space telescope
jwst is named after james e webb nasa's
second administrator who oversaw the
agency's decade-long effort to reach the
moon
he believed nasa had to put as much
emphasis on pushing space science as
human space flight
this next generation telescope is not
only 100 times more powerful than hubble
but its ability to see infrared opens up
a world of opportunities
it means that scientists are now able to
detect frequencies of light that are
invisible to hubble the hubble space
telescope operates primarily in the
optical so the wavelengths that you and
i can see
but as we look at the most distant
galaxies in the universe because the
universe is expanding those galaxies are
in in essence receding from us at faster
and faster speeds and that means that
their light is shifted from the visible
into the near infrared so in fact when
we want to see the very most distant
galaxies the first ones which ever
formed in the universe hubble can't see
them it's
unable to see at the right wavelengths
and also it's not really big enough to
see those extremely faint objects
this shift in wavelengths is known as
redshift and the result is that the most
distant objects emitting visible light
are invisible to telescopes tuned to
optical wavelengths
so you need a big telescope operating in
the infrared like jwst in order to see
those very first galaxies the ones which
are moving so fast away from us that all
of their light is redshifted into the
infrared
now jwst's largest program during its
first cycle is going to put those
capabilities to the test
the cosmos web survey is going to be
looking 13.5 billion years into the past
about 200 to 300 million years after the
big bang
and what it's going to be able to do is
observe galaxies that are much further
away from us than we've been able to do
before so we're going to be able to find
some of the earliest galaxies that have
formed in the universe
the hubble deep field looked at one part
of the sky and and stared there for a
long time and that was really our first
look into the distant universe
with cosmos web we are going to go a big
step beyond that so not only will we be
able to look
at objects that are much farther away
from us and much deeper into the
universe's history we're going to cover
a much larger area of the sky so we're
going to be able to observe
many many thousands more galaxies than
were able to be seen in the small area
of the hubble deep field
[Music]
so right now with hubble at these early
universe time periods you don't see very
many and what you see is kind of a
smudge just a little bit of a blob with
jwst we'll be able to resolve structure
and we'll learn a lot about the
properties of our very early universe
how the earliest structures first
started to grow but jwst will also tell
us a lot about how those galaxies
evolved from the very early universe
until today because we'll be able to see
galaxies across a wide range of
distances all the way back so we can put
together a timeline of how galaxies
evolve and how their structures have
grown overall
the images are going to have a very high
resolution which means we can resolve a
lot of structures and see really fine
details that we can't do with hubble so
i fully expect some of the initial
images we see are going to be jaw
dropping and so overall we estimate that
we're going to detect several thousand
galaxies in the very early universe but
how many we actually detect tells us
something very important about the
physics so even if we detect less than
we expect that's still really
interesting from a scientific point of
view
if you had spoken to people that were
expecting observations from the first
hubble data when hubble first launched
and told them about all the amazing
discoveries hubble has made since then
it would probably blow their mind right
they never would have imagined we'd see
galaxies as far away as we do or that
we'd observe you know planets around
other stars etc so we fully expect the
james webb space telescope will find
things we never even knew to ask about
unlike jwst we can't see infrared light
with the human eye but we can detect it
through heat or experience it visually
using an infrared camera
infrared light you can sort of think of
it like heat radiation so everything
glows in infrared you know you and i are
glowing in infrared
a lot of things in space give off
infrared light too
like stars nebulae and galaxies
but to detect the faint faraway target
scientists are after jwst has to be away
from the earth's warm atmosphere
and the problem is with hubble is that
hubble is actually quite warm hubble is
in low earth orbit
and it's about the same temperature as
the earth and that means it's actually
emitting in the infrared
and that's a bad thing if you want to
detect faint infrared light from very
far away
because you're swamped by the light
coming from the telescope itself
so the james webb space telescope has to
be cold
really cold
minus 233 degrees celsius cold
so the way we achieve that is firstly by
making the telescope open it doesn't
have a tube around it but what it does
have is a huge sun shield and the
telescope sits behind that sun shield
we're also located at a place called l2
one and a half million kilometers away
from the earth
where the sun and the earth are always
on the same side of the telescope
in this location the telescope's main
instruments can cool to near absolute
zero temperatures and receive the
infrared light
then they can take that light and
produce images or analyze the light to
learn what materials are present
this is known as spectroscopy and is a
major feature of jwst's science
instruments
[Music]
we have four instruments on the
telescope and these different
instruments are optimized to do
different things so obviously the
imagers take images of the universe in
both the near infrared and the
mid-infrared part of the spectrum the
spectrographs take spectra of different
objects in the universe so spectra are
sort of like you can think of as like
fingerprints of the objects so spectre
helped tell us about the chemical
components
and what atoms and molecules are in the
various different things that we're
looking at
using two of these instruments nearcam
and near spec and the power of the
telescope one team is going to be able
to take images and reveal the
composition of individual stars in our
nearest large galaxy
the andromeda galaxy
so we'll be looking 2.5 million years
into the past
that means that the light that we're
seeing was emitted by the galaxy 2.5
million years ago
andromeda is the nearest large galaxy to
the milky way it's our sort of twin if
you like they're both disc galaxies and
it's actually moving towards the milky
way as well they're kind of
gravitationally pulling each other
towards one another and eventually will
actually collide
we see the milky way from inside and
that means we can you know we can just
see the individual stars in the sky when
we look at galaxies outside the milky
way we just see them as a whole and you
can't really pick out individual stars
the great thing about andromeda is we're
still looking at it from the outside in
but we can actually pick out individual
stars in the disk of andromeda which it
makes it a fantastic tool for doing this
kind of comparison where you want to
extend the science that we're doing in
the milky way to this whole kind of
galactic population
because we studied the milky way in so
much detail it's kind of like the
rosetta stone of galaxy formation that
we can use to sort of inform our
understanding of galaxies but of course
then if the milky way
is an outlier and galaxies like
andromeda look much more kind of
run-of-the-mill then that means a lot of
the things that we know about the milky
way are not so useful
other telescopes while there's plenty of
telescopes that are good they're just
not quite good enough to do this task
so we're going to take spectra of 300
stars in the disk of andromedae and so
what that means is by measuring the
regions of those spectra where we see
less light we can actually understand
the element abundances like oxygen
magnesium and silicon before we take
those spectra we're going to use the
near cam which is the near infrared
camera
and we're going to essentially use that
to take images of andromeda before we go
and take these spectra to make sure that
we can really target the regions of the
galaxy that we need to
what i'm interested in doing is sort of
going and checking whether this this
characteristic element abundance
distributions that we see in the milky
way is present in andromeda which is
something that we've not been able to do
without jwst
we know that all the galaxies we see in
the universe have kind of been forming
throughout the whole history of our
universe so galaxies that we see are
like a sort of fossil record
of the whole of galaxy formation if you
could link all of the dots together and
you understood galaxy formation very
well you could actually turn back the
clock on all the physics that happened
in those galaxies and get to something
like the initial conditions of our
universe where all of everything came
from and i think those things are just
kind of interesting and a project like
this is kind of telling us about the
origins of our own galaxy you know most
of us want to know where we came from
building a telescope that has enough
power and sophistication to enable these
sorts of projects wasn't straightforward
engineers had to come up with a
completely new design in comparison to
hubble
so this telescope has this giant mirror
about six and a half meters across about
22 feet
and it has a sun shield that's the size
of a tennis court and so it's sort of an
odd looking design an odd looking
telescope the reason it was designed
this way is because it's so big it
stands about four stories tall so it's
too big for any rocket
to fit inside all unfolded in a rocket
so we had to fold it up to fit inside
the rocket and it unfolded once it was
in space
since space bound rockets do fail from
time to time over three decades of work
10 billion dollars and thousands of
scientists work were on the line
from a tropical rainforest to the edge
of time itself james webb begins a
voyage back to the birth of the universe
honestly the launch was definitely not
the hardest part of this mission
so following launch we had two weeks of
really intense
complex complicated deployments to get
this telescope unfolded and i myself and
i think all of us on the team were
really on the edge of our seats to wait
for these this deployments to happen
given its distance to earth if something
went wrong with jwst's deployments there
wouldn't be repair missions like there
was with hubble
the deployment of the sunshield was
particularly intense
the sun shield itself is five layers and
it had to unfold and then deploy the
five layers and there were hundreds of
release mechanisms on the sunshield that
all had to to release at just the right
time in just the right way there were
quite a few single point failures so
that if if one release mechanism didn't
work there would be nothing we could do
to fix it and so this particular part of
the deployments watching the sun shield
deploy was incredibly stressful
but everything went off so well
the engineers have built an
amazing incredible telescope and after
that two weeks you know i think all of
us took a deep breath there was
definitely a big celebration after the
last part of the deployments happened
[Music]
the launch was so incredibly efficient
using less fuel than anticipated it
extended the mission from five years to
an estimated 10 to 15 years
months later after the instruments had
called there were a series of
calibrations to make sure everything was
aligned
the primary mirror is made up of 18
different segments and those segments
had to be perfectly aligned once the
telescope was in space so what we did
was point the telescope at a bright star
and then you essentially get back an
image of 18 different stars and so from
using that image and sort of tracing the
star image to the different segments we
were able to individually move and tweak
each segment to get the telescope to
align on this star
each mirror had to be aligned to within
the billionth of a meter to form a
single primary mirror
that required making ultrafine
adjustments equal to 1 10 000 the width
of a human hair
which took roughly three months to
complete
so once that was done we got back this
beautiful image of what's otherwise a
boring star
that showed that proved that the
telescope was aligned
for me one of the most exciting things
about this boring star image is the fact
that in this relatively short exposure
you could see galaxies in the background
and so it gave us a little hint of
what's to come with this telescope
the star calibration image gave us the
first glimpse of jwst's power
it will give scientists the ability to
peer into star-forming regions and to
witness their birth more clearly than
ever before
we'll be looking back in time between
twenty thousand and two hundred thousand
years
we will be looking at three massive
star-forming regions one is in the milky
way our galaxy and two are in nearby
galaxies the magellanic clouds
ngc 3603 is a massive star forming
regions located at about 20 000 light
years away from us in the milky way
and it is made up of many stars many
massive stars some of which are even 100
times more massive than the sun but
there are many many smaller stars stars
like the sun the tarantula nebula is
located in the large magellanic cloud at
a distance of about 150 000 light years
the tarantula is a massive nursery of
star formation there are millions of
stars there that were just born and some
of them are still being created being
formed
and the third region that we want to
study is called ngc 346 is further away
still about 200 000 light years in the
small magellanic cloud yet another
galaxy
in each one of these regions we will
select about 100 stars and we will look
at them very carefully by blocking
everything else we want to get only the
light of those that we are interested so
we can disperse the light and produce a
spectrum very clean
but then with the camera we will look at
the entire regions and there will be
easily
millions of stars that we'll be seeing
in these parts
we will be looking at the massive stars
but we are particularly interested in
stars like the sun because those are the
most likely ones to have planets around
them
the main goal is to understand what is
the difference in the way in which stars
form
in our own galaxy and also in nearby
galaxies
but unfortunately visible light doesn't
travel well in regions where you have
lots of dust and gas
and the regions where stars are forming
are full of dust
so
in those regions it's very difficult for
visible light to go through
but infrared light
has longer wavelength so the light
rays are able to go around those
particles and we can see light even when
there is lots of dust so we can see
through the dust
[Music]
stars are the building block of galaxies
they produce most of the power the light
in the universe and they also make up
the elements elements like carbon oxygen
nitrogen iron
most of the elements in our body were
actually made up in a star and in fact
there is more some of the heavy elements
in our body like
gold
copper zinc
actually formed when a massive star
exploded as supernova so
even though
studying how stars form will not tell us
who we are as human beings it will
definitely make us understand make us
realize that without stars we would have
never been there in the first place
but it's not all about stars and
galaxies
jwst was also built with a relatively
new exciting field in mind
exoplanets
planets that are outside of our own
solar system
although there weren't any confirmed
exoplanets while hubble was being
designed and built it has contributed
significantly to this emerging field
giving us this first visible light image
of one
now there are over 5 000 confirmed
exoplanets and in the last few decades
we've learned that the overwhelming
majority of stars have planets
jwc has capability to study exoplanet
atmospheres to a degree and precision
that has never been done before and so
the infrared part of the spectrum offers
a really great insight into some of the
really interesting chemicals that might
be in a planet's atmosphere things like
water vapor and carbon dioxide and
methane things that could possibly
signal a surface that is habitable
and there's one particular system that's
on everyone's mind
it's called trappist-1
and it has multiple planets in the
habitable zone
the orbital region around a star in
which an earth-like planet can have
liquid water on its surface and possibly
support life
we will be looking about 40 years back
in time which is literally in our
backyard
the trappist system is what we can call
the rock star of exoplanet this is a
star that is very small not much bigger
than jupiter and that stars has not one
but seven planet transiting its star
and we know that these planets are of
mass and sizes similar to the earth and
three of them and maybe four are right
in the evitable zone and this system is
very close to the earth 40 light years
away and this is the one that will be
looking very hard to find whether these
planets have atmospheres and
you know if there's a system to point
where there's maybe life that's the one
the type is one system
[Music]
the hubble space telescopes tried to
detect the atmospheres and so far has
failed and we need a very powerful
telescope like james webb to detect the
atmosphere finding whether they have
oxygens water all the molecules that are
required for life as we know on earth
there are several methods but the one
that will be used very much by james
webb is the the transit method this is a
by chance you have a planet that goes in
front of its star from our perspective
and you can see a little uh light
dipping as the planet goes in front of
the star and that allows us to measure
the radius of the planet uh but also we
can actually probe the atmosphere so the
light that is filtered by the stars by
you know measuring the colors of the
atmospheres gives us a lot of
information about the atmosphere it's
called transit spectroscopy
and that's a technique that's been used
with hubble
but with some limited performance and
the the james west-based telescope will
be very well optimized to do these kinds
of very delicate observations
the trappist-1 system is by far the best
system this is the one that will give us
the the strongest signal
and uh there will be lots of time
devoted to that system with all science
instrument onboarded in jwst it is to do
with the fact that the star is very
close so there's lots of light we can
get from the telescope and also the
relative size of the planets of the star
is really large and that makes things
much easier we love small star and big
planet and for earth-like planet well
the trappist-1 system is just a perfect
system
i think just knowing that these planets
have an atmosphere
and knowing that we have a planet in the
evitable zone and there's water on it
that would be a big big deal and that
would be a first step is look this is
here we need to look in that system
[Music]
dr doyon was among the scientists who
worked on the telescope as principal
investigator of the instrument provided
by the canadian space agency
the telescope was such a massive
undertaking with numerous science goals
and technical challenges that it
required the collaboration of nasa the
canadian space agency and the european
space agency
so with the james webb space telescope
which astronomers started thinking about
as early as the end of the 80s even
before hubble was launched
european astronomers were involved along
with our american colleagues and with
the canadians
from the beginning from the outset and
build a bigger and better telescope that
would be possible with just one agency
alone
scientists who worked on the telescope
for allotted time but anyone could
submit proposals from anywhere in the
world
uh this whole process is dual anonymous
so don't know who's proposing and who's
doing the grading and that's the way
that the telescope time is allocated
one of the great things about these nasa
astrophysics missions is that anyone in
the world with a good idea can apply to
use time on the telescope and that
happens you know we get proposals from
around the world to use the telescope
and at the end of the day the best
proposals are
chosen anonymous proposals meant that
bias was kept to a minimum and ensured
that jwst covered a broad range of
science goals
even ones focusing on our own solar
system
we are looking at the furthest
regions of our solar system so this is
4.6 hours that the light takes to come
to the earth
the acronym trans-neptunian objects tnos
these are objects that are orbiting
beyond the orbit of neptune so in the
coldest regions of our solar system
there are estimated to be billions of
transneptunian objects even if at this
moment we have only discovered around
3000 of them
one of the most pristine um bodies in
our solar system that means
that they have been
not too much processed since they formed
so they hold clues and they hold
information from the very first stages
of the formation of the solar system
this basically means that they are like
frozen time capsules that are there
waiting for us to unveil those secrets
the largest objects
in the international unveiled together
with pluto is haumea iris and makamake
and because they are so large
they have an activity they may have an
atmosphere they have a lot of isis like
methane nitrogen co
those are in the largest pianos and we
think they were an ingredient for the
formation of the all the tnos but when
it comes to really know what is on the
surface of these objects
we don't really know
so we want to look if in the smaller
tinos there are also some kind some
amounts of these sizes we want to know
which are the ingredients that are on
the surface
and which is the state the physical and
chemical state of these ingredients
the recipe to cook a small body we have
60 tnos in our sample we have
representation of all the colors what we
are doing is
we take the light that comes from one of
these bodies and then is channeled
through this instrument is called
near-spec and this is a near-infrared
spectrograph near-spec is going to
observe in a part of the light that
can't be reached for tianos from the
earth
so
we are just separating
the light to get to know really
each single material that can be there
so jay's web comes on time
and it's perfect to do this this science
because it's out of the atmosphere
we have a preconceived idea of what is
at you know based on the knowledge that
we have
but our knowledge is limited and the
best things about tools like jwst is
that they are really discovery tools
they are going to provide us
with
many answers to questions that we didn't
even
know
we had
apart from jwst many ground-based
telescopes will be coming online in the
next few years complementing the science
jwst will do
like the vera rubin observatory in chile
estimators come online in 2023
it is a wide survey telescope expecting
to discover thousands of new objects
like tnos so then telescopes like jwst
can look at them in more detail
and the next big space telescope is just
around the corner
the big telescopes like hubble and jwst
only come along you know once every
couple of decades and the next big
telescope like this that we're building
is the nancy grace roman space telescope
so that particular telescope is not
quite as big or expensive as jwst but it
is also an infrared telescope that's
designed to see the universe in more of
a broad sort of swath so telescopes like
hubble and jwst are designed to see
small parts of the universe very deeply
but by looking a little less deep but
more wide we can learn different things
about the universe
people often ask you know are these
telescopes worth it we're spending a lot
of money on these telescopes
jrst is 10 billion
hubble from its inception in the late
70s all the way to now is about 16
billion dollars and so the question of
is it worth it is an important one these
are funded by taxpayers and of course
all of that money that's quote unquote
sent into space is spent right here on
earth of course you know funding
high-tech jobs but in addition to that i
think if we look at the past 30 years of
hubble and what we foresee as a bright
future with jwst
if you put that in the context of you
know money spent per year it turns out
to be less than a cup of coffee a cheap
cup of coffee per citizen per year
human beings are curious we all want to
know from where we come yes we exist
because stars exist and so it's good for
us to understand what are the elements
and the processes that are actually
needed for us as human beings to exist
i know for myself you know thinking over
the past year the past couple of years
with so much going on in the world and
so much negativity having the positivity
of a mission like this to look forward
to and something that's working and
successful and is a symbol of people all
over the world working together to
achieve something that is
technologically amazing for me that's
awe-inspiring and and gives me hope for
the future of humanity it's so easy to
get wrapped up in things that are
happening on planet earth
and not go and think about these
beautiful things that we see but then on
the other hand it's like you know things
like understanding how stars work can
teach us about nuclear fusion for
example
the way that the elements are produced
in the universe you know i think it's
just a fundamental question that human
beings should want to know
historically whenever a new facility is
put together and you ask a question five
ten years later what was the main
discovery that the cioscope made nobody
could predict it can talk to you about
all the kind of stuff we think we're
gonna be doing but you know what we
don't know and that's the most exciting
part of this who has not wondered about
looking at the sky who does not wonder
about
knowing that we are not alone
all of that knowledge that wonders us it
comes because someone
asked himself
what is that that is out there
[Music]
you